ils sont venus défendre l'hôpital public
ce mardi devant un établissement de
santé lyonnais des centaines de
manifestants ont répondu à l'appel lancé
par les syndicats cgt et sud ainsi que
le comité interrogeant ce soignant
personnels hospitaliers médecins ont
réclamé l' embauche de personnel et la
réouverture de lit on est là parce qu'il
faut aider les soignants et les
soignantes
c'est plus possible ça fait des années
maintenant que l'hôpital public qui
souffrent le gouvernement il donne rien
les primes s'est même pas tous les
soignants
alors c'est beau de faire des
applaudissements inventaire il faut des
actions faut de l'argent pour l'hopital
public peep et il a sauvé mon nom je
dirais plus de moyens mois du personnel
et des blouses blanches soutenue par
divers mouvements contestataires présent
dans la manifestation
plusieurs organisations de gauche et
même des gilet jaune
[Applaudissements]
j'ai 62 ans je me bats contre tout
l'état français nos gouvernements et
monsieur macro je suis là aujourd'hui
pour aussi défendre l'hôpital public
c'est à dire les salaires des infirmiers
des ambulanciers des brancardiers et
leur retraite à ne pas toucher l'état
n'a pas été capable de pourvoir les
hôpitaux masse n'a pas été capable de
protéger ses citoyens tout savoir que de
nombreux soignants temps était malade et
qui sont encore malades
il faut savoir que les gens sont
fatigués
le en région parisienne dans les et la
france a été une catastrophe la région
lyonnaise à un peu moins souffert mais
je vous assure que jose d'aujourd'hui et
d'antan seront les bienvenus ce qu'on
veut ce sont des bras des gens qui
viennent nous aider des gens comme
arrête de sous-payer à l'hôpital pour
expliquer vous qu'aujourd'hui une
infirmière qui débutent ou une
manipulatrice radio qui débute comme en
salle à 1400 euros brut
bac + 3 comment voulez vous motiver les
gens à venir faire carrière à l'hôpital
il dénonce fermement la casse de
l'hôpital public et réclament une hausse
de salaire de 400 euros mensuels pour
tous les agents hospitaliers ainsi qu'un
des gel du point d'indicé bloqué depuis
leur objectif l'arrêt total de la
politique de fermetures de lits pour
redonner à l'hôpital sa mission de
service public des revendications
récurrentes alors que la crise sanitaire
provoquée par le kobe 19 n'est toujours
pas terminée une mobilisation qui arrive
également au lendemain du ségur de santé
lancée par le gouvernement un projet
censé refonder l'hôpital public
d'après le ministre olivier véran les
engagements prix devrait être bouclée
d'ici le début du mois de juillet